[Music]
we're live on location at Stanford
University and joining me today is an
economist author scholar senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution and living
legend dr. Thomas all welcome to the
Rubin report well thank you good to be
with you I feel I have to get the
gushing out first that way we can focus
on the book I don't know that there's
anyone on this mortal coil who's writing
and thinking has influenced me more than
you so this this is truly an honor for
me and I just have to get that out right
at the beginning I just hope I haven't
miss laser yeah we'll find out I'll let
you know at the end so first I thought I
want do a little bit on your history and
I want to focus on your new book but I
was curious if you have a sense of the
sort of Renaissance that your writing is
having right now with young people
because when I tweet it out that we
finally had you on the show and we've
been trying to make this happen for
quite some time I mean thousands of
responses and I had tons of people just
says please tell him this tell him this
my awakening was because of dr. Tsao all
this are you noticing something
happening right now because of the
unique police work I only know what
people tell me that's even true at
Stanford yeah I only know what my
research is sisters televisions all
right well I will certainly accept that
well take my word for it then so I want
to talk a little bit about your history
for a bit and then we'll then we'll move
on to your new book born North Carolina
yes
grew up in the Bronx Harlem in Harlem
sorry in Harlem tell me a little bit
about some of your formative years well
you know I thought about as I was doing
the research for the first chapter where
I get into the Bur sort of thing now had
my my parents lived a normal lifespan I
would have been the sixth child in the
family they died young and so I was
adopted in infancy and a family as it
only traces an only child in a home with
four adults and in terms of what what I
found in the research on birth order
clearly that was a huge advantage
and so their misfortune was my good
fortune and moreover the family in which
I was raised moved to New York which at
that time had a foster period
educational system that in North
Carolina and foster period of what it is
today
were you always interested in education
I mean even as you know I got a kid a
little kid there was nothing in my
background that will put me there
but fortunately when in Harlem knows a
kid named ready that members of the
family had run into before I ever
arrived from North Carolina on it and he
was a very came from a highly educated
family and they immediately saw the
implications if they could get him to to
sort of mentor me and now I had I had
met Eddie on my own chances I would
never have seen any significance he was
just a vision one of the people I passed
by but of course the other the adults
understood what the future was like and
then thinking about things that kids
don't think about despite the great
worship which a child talkers these days
and so but so he took me to a public
library and I had no idea what a public
library was I was eight years old and I
saw all these books and I had no idea
why we were there when I don't have any
money to buy one book and so what am I
gonna do with all these you know
hundreds of books up on the shelf
and he very patiently walked me through
the whole thing
and again I was very reluctant to take
out a library cause hiding to watch what
all this is about that but he talked me
into it
and I said I bought a couple of books
and really had I not encountered him the
entire rest of the story could not have
been the way it was I mean at some point
I would have learned what a public
library was but by that point it would
be too late yeah I mean when you start
getting in the habit of reading when
you're eight years old
that's a different ballgame than if you
have to wait till you're a teenager it's
too late now
dare I ask if you have any recollection
what you might have taken out of the
library at eight years old one of the
books was the Doctor Dolittle
books I don't know if you know what
those are I think he could talk to the
animals yeah Alison Wonderland
and the rest of them but the I came in
on May and there wasn't school wasn't
open until September so I had no one to
play with and I was just bored to tears
and so I started reading really for the
first time and I got the habit of
reading and on that you know that made
the rest possible yeah were there any
other formative things that happened to
you over those those younger years yes
the same the same fellow it was very
knowledgeable but all about the school
system so when I finished elementary
school and they assigned me to a junior
high school in a very bad neighborhood
he told me that you you can get
transferred and I in fact got
transferred to a much better school
had I gone to that other school I again
the story would have been entirely
different and I one of the one of the
themes of the early part of the book
here is that there are there a whole
number of things that have to come
together and if you don't have all of
those prerequisites then all the
whatever good qualities you have don't
matter and I mentioned illiteracy that
you know in the middle of the 20th
century something like 40% of the adults
in the world we're still illiterate and
so it doesn't matter what their native
talent or any of that came along you
can't read there are a whole lot of
occupation you just simply can't get
into yeah so it's pretty clear from all
the reading of yours that I've done you
put basic education basically is number
one right I mean is that the number one
thing that you can do as a human being
get educated
I guess although I wouldn't carry it too
far because some of the most disastrous
notions in the world who come from
highly educated people with I'm sure
high IQs so perhaps critical thinking
with a little education though I am I
will settle for almost any kind of thing
it's so really that it is oddly rare so
one of the things that I found out that
was sort of amazing about your history
you briefly mentioned it right before we
started you were a Marxist at one time
in your life most people will find this
hard to believe but it is true
but it's not that unusual
most of the leading conservative
thinkers of our time did not start off
as conservator you got a couple like
Bill Buckley and George Will but I mean
Milton Friedman was it was it was a
liberal and a Keynesian a Hayek was a
socialist Ronald Reagan was so far left
at one point the FBI was following him
you know so so there's a huge movement
from the left to the right as people get
older yeah I'm I'm well aware as I
mentioned to you earlier as a former
progressive I understand that that
movement in the modern sense
do you remember sort of what you were
thinking what appeal to you at that time
about Marxism yes I mean there was no
alternative being discussed my first job
was as a Western Union messenger and I
would come home on some nights I would
take the Fifth Avenue bus which cost all
of 15 cents in those days but I figured
I'd splurge now and then and I would
drive it would go away up Fifth Avenue
pass all these Lord and Taylor and all
these fancy places and then across 57th
Street pass Carnegie Hall and down
Riverside Drive now it's sort of the
Gold Coast area and then yes I came
across this long viaduct and it turned
into 130 Fifth Street
suddenly there were the tenements and I
wondered why is this
I mean it's so so it's so different and
then nothing in in schools or most of
the books seem to deal with that and
walks dealt with that so it's it's it's
like winning in an election when there's
only one person running so then what was
your wake up to what was wrong with that
line of thinking facts well we could
probably end the interview right there
facts and specifically my first
professional job I was a summer intern
at the new US Department of Labor and I
realized from dealing with these people
that the US Department of Labor one of
my biggest concern was about minimum
wages it has been for a long time and so
my first night well this is good because
all these people look poor and he'll get
a little higher
and come and so that'll that'll be
helpful and then it's like studied
economics ever gonna see well there's a
downside they may lose their jobs
completely sort of is that and so I
tried when I was at the Labor Department
I tried to talk about that to them and
eventually I came up with some test of
it and when I came up with this test how
we might test this I was waiting to hear
congratulations you said I've had this
and I can see these people were stunned
I said oh this is idiot has stumbled on
something that will ruin us all and I
realized the US Department of Labor had
its own agenda and interests and that
did necessary not necessarily mean that
then that whether four people lost their
jobs or minimum wages when it got higher
pay was their highest priority yeah how
much longer did you last know that would
know that was really the turning point
yeah and then I began to see that all
these government agencies more knots
they have their own institutional
incentives and and you cannot say that
the government is will step in and do
what's right for these people or what
not because they'll do what's right for
themselves so I think a lot of people
watching this and I know because I've
been so open about my own sort of
awakening are going through this right
now they're realizing that the things
that they've been taught for so long are
not the the truth and are not based in
fact when that happened to you and you
started telling other people not just
the people you were working with be it
family and friends what kind of pushback
did you get because it was sort of
radical ideas in a way that you were
talking about that well I find I didn't
feel any need to do a lot a lot of
proselytizing it was enough for me that
that I was now beginning to understand
things I hadn't understood before and
you've noted in the book I have a
mission minimum wage studies and really
they're they're they are incredibly
flawed there's a whole chapter on
numbers and the other thing getting back
to my personal development I mean I left
home when I was 17 no high school
diploma no excuse no job experience and
I discovered that there was not a huge
amount of demand for people like that
but in retrospect decades later when I
do research I realize that in 1948 the
unemployment rate for black 16 and
17-year olds was nine point four for
whites the same age it was ten point two
and those numbers are much smaller than
we were used to in recent decades and
there's no serious racial difference in
fact the blacks and at my age bracket
we're doing just slightly better and of
course one of the things that the
minimum wage law does is that it it
creates unemployment raised it to
multiples of what it was 1948 was that
was a special time because the minimum
wage law was passed in 1938 and in the
intervening ten years there was huge
inflation and the law hadn't gotten
changed and so for all practical
purposes there was no minimum wage law
but had we had these wonderful liberals
insisting that I be paid a living wage
that would support a family of four I
would have been unemployed and I don't
know what that would have let him write
it would probably would not have led up
to everything else so when you wouldn't
when you think about these wonderful
liberals as you just said you know I
think there's sort of two lines of
thinking one is that you know the road
to hell is paved with good intentions I
try not to be super highway it's a super
highway exactly I try not to besmirch
their intentions but then I think there
are people that are either can have
confused thinking or have ulterior
motives
or else what do you think it is as
someone that is so based in fact and
we're gonna get to have plenty of that
fact in a moment what do you think the
thinking is the flaw in the thinking oh
I think it's the idea that you don't
have to check a good-sounding idea
against what actually happens the whole
19th and there are people to this day
who think that the 1960s was just a
great period and and I'll say to them do
you realize how many good trends they're
there the murder rate among black males
had gone down had been going down for
two decades you know by 18 percent in
one decade 22 percent a nice decade and
in 1960
suddenly takes a u-turn straight up and
that was not peculiar to blacks or even
to the United States
Pinker's book about about violence and
you know that throughout what the
Western world the homicide rates did a
u-turn in the 1960s so the question is
what actually happens when you put your
wonderful ideas to work do they produce
the kind of thing you thought they were
gonna produce or do they produce all the
opposite in many areas and they produce
lots of offices yeah I'm glad you
mentioned Steven Pinker I had him on the
show a few weeks ago and I think he's
you know he's one of the clearest
thinkers we have and you know his new
book enlightenment now is that things
are trending more positively
but even hearing that is is very hard
for a lot of people well honey depends
on what your baseline is Pinker is much
more optimistic than I am I I happen to
be very pessimistic about the future but
I hope the optimists are right do you do
you think you're a pessimist by Nature
no but I think having study of so many
things that sounded so good and ended up
so bad it makes me doubt especially when
they're people who are anxious to spout
off with very little study of what
they're talking about yeah we've got a
lot of that these days do you think that
has ramped up or yeah I think social
media seems to amplify things but do you
think it's always been that way about
just sort of this endless pontificating
of people that really don't know what
they're talking about well there's
always been that as long as they've been
human beings but the question is the
magnitude of it and the ability of
various institutions to shut out any
other viewpoint of which the
universities are the worst examples yeah
that I mean when I when I when I see the
riots when charles murray shows up and i
haveno charles murray
I mean if you can demonize Charles where
you can demonize anybody yeah I mean and
I listen to see what are they gonna
quote that he said I've never heard a
single quote of all the books the man
has written and they never quote
anything he said and a lot of what he
said is a direct opposite of what they
claimed he said that tells you a little
bit about state we're in right now so do
you so this
this thing that's happening on college
campuses right now that everyone seems
to think is freezing free speech and and
it seems to be speeches speech that's
generally thought of as right so it's
conservatives libertarians further
people on the right than that you're
saying that's really not a new
phenomenon you you were kind of well it
was not that bad in the nineteen fifties
when I was a Marxist and when Senator
Joe McCarthy was Kara was tracking down
anybody on the Left but I said whatever
I felt like where I felt like it and I
got no such blowback that's really
interesting so McCarthy is talking about
all this stuff but you had no problem
no being at okay here in Washington I
was in Cambridge yeah so--but yeah so
you do think if something has gotten
worse now oh no there was a number of
things you add vanilla diseases for
example well going down at a very steep
rate it was either syphilis or gonorrhea
that was one half as prevalent in 1960
as it was in 1950 that the brilliant
idea was to bring in sex education you
see to avoid unwanted pregnancies and so
on and venereal diseases skyrocketed
unwanted pregnancies teenage pregnancies
skyrocketed it's amazing that so many
people on the Left are able to just
ignore any facts they go against their
theory yeah an image it just does not my
my old mentor at the University of
Chicago enjoy Stiegler organ however
that economists have very little
influence and what what they say makes
very little difference and he was giving
a talk at the Hoover Institution once he
said thanks to the years of dedicated
work by Tom Sowell the next minimum wage
increase will be five cents or less than
it would have been otherwise well that's
what's interesting to me is because as I
as I preface this with you I think that
the writings that you've done all these
years in these books they're becoming
culturally relevant maybe in a way that
they weren't I don't even want to say it
this way but maybe in a way that they
didn't weren't economically relevant do
you understand the point there that I
think there's a cultural relevance to
all the things that you've done for
these last you know forty some odd years
that
seem so actually powerful and impactful
to me right now
which is incredible well when it comes
to impact that's a difference the story
entirely I mean long ago I stopped
accepting invitations to testify before
congressional committees it's an
absolute waste of time they have made up
their minds and they just want to be
able to say they've heard all points of
view and then it pretty much stops there
that's right and I remember once Kenneth
Clark was I was debating him and he was
beside himself because my said suppose
it's sinister influence in Washington
this during the Reagan administration I
told him it might have my influence in
Washington is all you have to worry
about very fortunate bad yeah I have had
I can't think of anything that happened
any different that if I had never said
anything to anybody
you're being very humble saying no I'm
just realistic I'm gonna die I can't I
can't find it I can remember testifying
before one committee and the audience
was so around that the Chairman had to
back bang the gavel that the key to shut
them down and and they put some little
tiny thing in it in the law they were
building and and I would bet the rent
money that that provision is gone now
because there are so many people who
didn't why I was saying that if you're
gonna help up for kids
then give the money to the kids are you
know from provided for wherever they go
don't turn it over to the institutions
because they they will then use it in an
entirely different way are there any
examples where the money is turned over
to the institution whatever the
institution might be where it really
does work are there any aberrations in
most the must there must be some where
by law of averages but is not prevalent
yeah so a couple times you've mentioned
liberals and one of the things that I
talked about on my show often because I
was I was a progressive I was I was a
lefty I now call myself a classical
liberal and I've tried to make the point
that being a liberal in the traditional
sense has very little if anything to do
with the left anymore yes are there any
do you see any sort of meaningful
distinction between classical liberal
and libertarian at this point or
or do you see even I'll ask you a couple
things at once and you can go any
direction do you see any are there do
you see a difference of course between
liberals and the left I mean the words
have all sort of yeah no I'm free-range
to always say that he was he was a
liberal sort of Hayek and and of course
in different countries the word means
different things are in Australia if you
said you were a liberal they would
understand what you were saying but in
it what a liberal and is Australia is
different from a liberal in the United
States yeah so when you say liberal you
mean leftist basic yeah and the American
sense of the word yeah do you think
there's any sort of real distinction
that needs to be made between classical
liberal and libertarian that that's one
of the things that people ask me all the
time and I know you're not big on labels
generally but I did read something where
you said that the closest thing that you
could be labeled as is libertarian is
that still where you're at yeah except
of course in foreign policy we can talk
about that too
and and and I guess also the little of
libertarians seem to have this atomistic
view of the world which i think is
completely unrealistic yeah sighs oh
good because I mean not only in my life
but in the lives of people around me the
surroundings make a huge difference one
of the things I get into a lot in in the
book is this the disparities imply
either either discrimination on the one
hand or genetic differences on the other
and disparities are the norm I mean I
was just reading something the other day
you know that Latin America has 8% of
the people in the world they commit 38%
of all the murders I and in Latin
America 80% no third 38% for that but in
Latin America eighty percent of the
murders occur on 2% of the streets Wow
so but you find that when you look look
up facts that's what you find over and
over again and it in all the discussions
of income the differences they acted
that it they never take into account age
an age is huge I mean japanese-americans
have a median age of 50 Hispanic
Americans has
26 now when you see Hispanic Americans
greatly over-represented among baseball
stars and not a single Japanese American
baseball star in the major leagues I
don't believe in entire history yeah
well we had each hero on scene oh no no
no that was there are people of Japanese
ancestry who've been become baseball
stars yeah all of them are from Japan
none of them are Japanese America hi
okay fair enough right he played he was
a star in Japan for that that's right
yeah so so so how many 50-year old men
are gonna be baseball stars yeah and by
the same token how many 20 26 year-old
men are gonna be surgeons or CEOs any
other kind of job that requires a long
years of study or and or long years of
experience and so even if they were the
same if the two groups were the same in
every other way and if there was
absolutely no distinction no
discrimination and whatnot they still
would be a huge difference in income
simply because of age and and that
really is what this book is about and
you know the book itself it's about a
hundred 60 pages but what I loved
you know many pages have notes you have
in there yep do you know offhand Wayne
well I know I know 127 pages are texts
and the rest of it is notes
yeah so you had about 30 some odd pages
notes and I actually started going
through the notes because I thought this
is this is exactly what we need now we
you know like when I was reading it
there were pages that I had to read more
than once because you're obviously
giving a lot of numbers and facts and
you have to look at these things from
different angles and we're not very good
at that these days right we're sort of
know knows from one angle and then and
then you start the screaming and I think
that's what you're you're really a
master up here yeah well thank you I'm
trying I try to but we'll see how it
works out we'll see do you make any
meaningful distinction between sort of a
classical liberal and a libertarian is
that is that just sort of that's wholly
peripheral that's what I'm coming there
just trying to get a few simple facts
across it's a full-time job yeah all
right so let's talk about some of the
facts that you lay out in the book you
talk about two types of discrimination
could yeah the word has almost opposite
meanings I mean the first meaning when
they say yes someone has discriminating
tastes you mean he can tell what
a good wine from a bad wine what does a
good camera from a [ __ ] and so forth
and that's almost the exact opposite of
the meaning and in the law where you
mean someone who judges someone by what
group he comes from irrespective of the
individuals actual personal qualities so
that no those are two very different
things
ideally you would like every person to
be judged as an individual but as a
practical matter that becomes impossible
because the costs are prohibitive yes I
use the example where if you're walking
down at night and and you see a shadowy
figure in an alley up ahead I mean do
you judge him as an individual or do you
cross the street and go across on the
other side because the cost of judging
him as an individual can be very high
including your life so so we make that
distinction but then I say that I call
that discriminate discrimination 1/1 is
when you just have a very good
understanding of what the facts are and
so if you judge this person as an
individual I call that discrimination 1a
and then if you judge them by the group
they belong to that's not as good but
that's discrimination wouldn't be but
it's still based on some facts a
discrimination tool which is what reason
we have any discrimination laws is that
you don't worry about that at all if
he's someone that you don't like for
whatever reason then you you you you you
know
biased against him yeah are you shocked
when you look at what's going on right
now and and see so much talk about race
all the time so much talk about all of
the things that separate us the very
things that that you've been arguing
against based in fact for so many years
that seem in an odd way more I don't
think there's more racism now than ever
or more of these dividers but there's
more talk about it yes and it's
devastating I mean what wars in general
are much easier to start than they ought
to stop I mean when when when that
fellow in in Serbia shot the Archduke I
mean who knew that that was going to
millions of people around the world
including people from the United States
about it's about ten thousand miles away
and I call
with install shooting yeah great war
yeah and and you can't get and you get a
none and I'm worried about the truck
current trade war you start a trade war
you may never be able to stop it in and
then in the next decade because there
are too many people involved too many
cross-current syringes and so on
[Music]
you